what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally getting back into
Doomsday Clock
and that's that's a crazy thing do say
o'clock comes out like once every two or
three months now like it's uh it's it's
basically a quarterly publication right
I mean is this kind of the weird thing
you know if DC rebirth is really going
back to the roots of comics it actually
kind of makes sense that DC would do
something like this I mean this is being
done because of you know just delays in
the title but back in the day like back
when you had like the all-star comics
like it was all-star quarterly like you
had quarterly comics that were released
by Marvel I'm sorry by DC that would
usually feature like team-ups different
things like that it was a cool concept
and in reality I wouldn't mind seeing DC
bring back quarterly you know quarterly
publications that are like big events or
something along those lines but it
doesn't need to be like Marvel worse
like a big crossover event every every
you know every quarter I mean that's the
best a little much but it does fit in
with the idea of fit in nicely with with
what DC is trying to achieve here now
really in the the last bit of Doomsday
Clock remember this is really kind of
Jeff John setting the stage for the post
Doomsday Clock
era of DC which is to say what comes
after Superman's conversation are really
probably even battle with dr. Manhattan
of course no idea how in the world
Superman's gonna win that fight what
this did is in a lot of ways it picked
up on really focused on mime and
marionette that's really what a lot of
of Doomsday Clock it done but up to this
point we'd also seen like the return of
Johnny Thunder or at least we seen his
character featured we saw the return of
the the Lantern of Allen Scott so like
we know Alan Scott's out there somewhere
he's kind of like these little bits and
bobs these small little tidbits that
Jeff John throws in that it's like the
return of the JSA now in truth again
when it comes to Montand marionette ah
they're basically just you know they're
copies of what's a patch and Julie I
think it is but they're basically plays
on characters that existed in Charlton
comics back in the day but with mime and
marionette there are essentially new
creations and so we didn't really know
what their story was we didn't really
know where they came from but the last
thing we'd seen is they found themselves
rolled up in the Joker and so of course
when it comes to to the character of
marionette herself and usually this
picks up with this whole scenario of her
father just least seemingly being
ransacked and her essentially watching
it all now what this does is it really
like sets the stage for the tone of the
story and really for the nature of them
because what it means is it it starts
things off by essentially saying this
girl comes from a very rough past and
that's one of the important things
because what you've also got is the two
of them having met the Joker and that's
the big difference here that's really
kind of how geoff johns juxtaposes the
joker with my
marionette and says they're not actually
the same thing because when we first saw
them when we first picked up with
Doomsday Clock and we looked at mine the
marionette is like okay so they're
basically Jeff John's version of what
would what Harley Quinn of the Joker
would be like but in reality that's not
the case that when it comes to the Joker
himself he's just an insane man
depending on what origin you're reading
either it's tragic or is just kind of
how things felt now the fact that Joker
has a Batman it's kind of somebody to
notice here of course we saw that play
out in the in Alaska in the last video
that we did in the last story so it's
not like it's it just kind of came out
of nowhere but it's not like he's he's
just like oh we got to take him and
torture him what we got to do all these
crazy things he's like yep I got Batman
business as usual like that's kind of
how it feels because what this is Jeff
Jones doing is saying yeah Joker's got
Batman and that's a big deal but there's
much bigger deals coming down the line
namely Superman and dr. Manhattan so
it's it's like the one thing everybody's
excited for but from here we basically
end up running into a handful of
henchmen basically of mr. freeze now
when the Joker comes across these guys
we end up finding out that mr. freeze is
kind of vanished now we'll find out
where he went to but they're like mr.
freeze is kind of vanished like we don't
really know where he went to he went off
the grid he's off the radar
and so the Joker's response is well then
join my crew now it's one of these
things where if the Joker comes across
your path and he extends you an
invitation to join his crew it's not
really an invitation you can turn down
now at this point we switch back to the
past of marionette you know with her her
father essentially you know running this
shop called maze glass and it's kind of
interesting because what what happened
there's another kid across the street
whose family runs another store
themselves now of course this guy is as
most of you guys have probably guessed
is essentially mine like he's the guy
that will grow up to become mine but
it's kind of cool because marionette and
like immediately takes a liking to but
the problem is that this kid doesn't
really talk he doesn't really say
anything and he's actually kind of a
standby like all these puppets and all
these things that are there so again
it's this kind of jumping back and forth
they're sort of switching back between
the origin of mine and marionette and
jumping back to the current moment but
one thing to also keep in mind here is
that mime and marionette weren't really
crazy they're just kind of out doing
their own thing and they basically play
up a gimmick that is in relation to
their characters of course marionette as
we know took up the mantle because she
her father was a was a you know was a
puppet guy and you know mime doesn't
really talk so we don't like the roles
they play reflect the lives they've led
but they've never encountered anyone
like the Joker before because rumored
mom and marionette are basically
displaced from the from the watchman
universe
and so they're used to more like
grounded people like people who were
villains but are really more of like
fly-by-night villains they're morally
more it's kind of goofy or they just
sort of do things you know like if a
crazy person you decide to dress up as
like a as a gladiator as I didn't want
to ride a sword like that's the kind of
villain that they're used to they're not
used to someone like the Joker the Joker
is so chaotic the Joker is so
unpredictable it makes it it makes it
crazy and when the options give it like
hey do you guys want to join my thing to
Joker's like no no no I'm a marionette
or like no no we're not going to but at
the same time they're also pretty
intense because they basically escape
the Joker's scheme is by like poking out
the eyes of one of the of one of the
henchmen with marionette decapitating
the other so it's not like they're
helpless right it's not like oh wow this
is a crazy situation but I don't know
how to deal with this not at all the
issue here is that when the Joker really
really comes with a joker takes out one
of his own guys that's really what kind
of baffles mom and marionette to a
degree and even baffles the henchman of
mr. Frese because for the most part it's
kind of be expected for us as the reader
but if your mom and marionette is just
kind of like this is a little weird but
the more they stay together the more
different they are the more similarities
they find they have between the other
but the fact remains here jumping back
to the past of marionette they're really
sort of coming together moment of of
marionette and mime comes in the fact
that marionettes basically being taunted
by a handful of bullies and so you know
they they literally like straight up and
then they hold her in place and just
start beating the crap out of her when
she starts to fight back and so of
course here comes mine cracks the bottle
over the head of one of them and then
just starts beating him with a broken
beer bottle now of course as we know
bullies don't get second chances and so
this literally leads to marionette just
like chasing this girl down like when
she flees for her life you know if she
chases her down it starts bubbling the
heck out of her she tries to apologize
and then in turn my marionettes like do
you have another bottle so we can help
this girl finish with all of her living
and so it is I mean it's it's like it's
pretty intense but here's one of the
other things to bear in mind - even at a
young age they're moving towards a
direction where it's just the two of us
that's really kind of the the road
they're going in and so it's kind of
cool because what is up happening is neo
following the Joker we end up finding
out that what's essentially happening
the reason why mr. freeze vanish is
because all the villains of DCF have
essentially located in one place or at
least the most notable villains so you
have like Hector ham and basically the
earth-based villains Hector ham and the
penguin two-face you know all these
different guys but they're all basically
being led by the Riddler The Riddler
basically says like we're all coming
together to form our own secret society
of super villain
or Legion of Legion of Doom or whatever
it is that you want to call it but it's
basically Jeff John's way of saying like
this old formation of the villains
banding together you know against like
this superhero community is gonna return
it's gonna come back but notice there's
kind of a veritable who's who here like
for example you have dr. sivana now of
course we know Sivan is gonna be here
because of the fact that Shazam is
coming back but you've also got like you
know Captain cold you've got boomerang
here's something else to that I don't
believe has been introduced yet in the
main line DC Comics you've got the judge
of Alice where you have the court of
owls and then you've got like the
monarchy of owls whatever in the world
is called now you've got the judge of
owls which is basically the one person
who's in charge of like all the owls of
the Batman mythos that exists out there
in in the world so it's kind of cool to
see that expanded but then you also see
them hitting at typhoon now typhoons a
character has been around for a long
long time so he's not really like a
rework of dr. Manhattan but here's a
funny thing he could be and the reason
why I say that is I mean the clueless
the clearest similarity between the two
is the color of their skin in fact
they're both blue but in truth David
Drake made his debut back in flash
number 294 way back in the day so again
he's been around for a very very very
long time his power is just weather
manipulation he's mostly been a flash
villain and his power has been confined
in a smaller scale he's never really
been like a major player but in reality
it wouldn't be that hard for dr.
Manhattan to just like take out the
original typhoon dress up as typhoon and
then go into the main DC Universe the
question is why like why would dr.
Manhattan do that which is why it's
really not a believable theory but it is
kind of a funny idea to sort of toy
around with but then from here we
basically switch back again to the
origin of marionette and this is when we
end up finding out that what had
basically been happening at this time
when she was a little kid is that her
father was basically being shaken down
by the cops that the cops were crooked
you know they were they were coming in
and they were saying like you owe us a
debt basically like you owe us a tie the
source of course they also end up
dropping the news that this young kid
Marco that Marcos bit his mom died she
essentially fell down a fire escape and
that was really the end of her but again
it's it's another one of these things
worse just like they they live a pretty
rough life there's a lot of really
really shady things going on here not
only that kind of jump me back to the to
the current moment we end up finding out
this is not the first time the Joker's
shown up with a Batman trying to get
himself into this team which is so Joker
it's exactly what Joker would do like
from what we're being told previously
the Joker had shown up with like a
prison guard from Arkham Asylum
dressed him as the Batman and said I've
captured the Batman see you guys can I
join your team now it's kind of a funny
little thing now of course this leads to
a bit of a skirmish between light
and the rest of the villains because
it's kind of like hey look your typhoon
like you really don't need to be here
man like you're pretty small-time and
then of course in the middle of all this
typhoon gets shot in the face and this
is when things really pop off because we
end up finding out the person who shot
typhoon in the face is the comedian and
dude okay so this is this is when things
get so awesome because then it's
literally a bloodbath
he's just firing on everyone like all
all these different villains he's taking
every last one of them out now mime
starts making his way over to try to
take out comedian and marionette
immediately calls him back but of course
he doesn't necessarily respond and set
like gigantic gets in the way of you
know comedian and then of course he kind
of has to Jim out of the way of her
onslaught but from there like it's
literally taking potshots I mean it's
just it's like it's like the punisher
rolled into like the hideout of like all
the Marvel villains and just start
shooting everybody to pieces that's what
the comedian's doing right now like he
literally shows up in this place and
just starts taking all of them out but
like most people here just kind of react
the way you would expect like they just
kind of scattered but like for most
people they don't really know what's
going on they're responsive a marionette
is we have to get out of here this is
the comedian he will kill us all but
notice this where we as the reader would
look at this and we would think that
initially the Joker has more in common
with mime and marionette than anybody
else the Joker actually has more in
common with a comedian that sure the
comedian is a vigilante but it's like
mime and marionette and the comedian
both represent different sides of the
Joker but it's basically like it's him
just it's a comedian like hey look I'm
gonna kill you all so like you can run
if you want to but I will find you I'll
track you down and then I'll then I'll
take you out so it's one of these crazy
things because it's like it's like this
is exactly how we would expect the
comedian's arrival to unfold in the this
whole landscape of DC comics and so
again switching back to this last you
know this this next little tidbit of
marionettes origin the cops show up
again but the issue is that the father
basically stands up and says I can't let
you guys shake me down anymore
especially not in front of my daughter
because what she's gonna do is she's
gonna grow up believing give people
whatever they want and life will be
easier which is a terrible way to live
the issue it is the response to this is
they grab they grab marionette they
bring around and they're like look you
can give us what we want or we will kill
your daughter what we end up finding out
is that the this guy you know that the
father is essentially is kind of like
he's B's
he's got a an actual financial tidy has
to pay money that has to be given which
is currently hidden inside the Nite Owl
doll which of course you know they crack
it open they take the money out and
that's been you know they end up leaving
that's where he stores you know the
extra cash and so what ends up happening
here is this this situation
where you know she goes and he after
this whole scenario she basically goes
and ends up hanging out with Marcos you
know and start something up hooking
around asking questions can you really
not talk like one of the ones going on
she returns back to the shop you know
after you know the next day or so only
to find that her father hung themselves
and this is when things get really
really crazy because now it's just her
she's alone there's no one else there
this is all that's left because her
father leaves a note behind that says
look Neil's Dean they would have never
stopped coming it's one of these things
if you give an inch you give a mile you
given to them the first time and they'll
keep coming back the only way to make
them stop is to get rid of them but in
this instance I'm leaving you behind
because now you can go out and you can
make your own make your own life and so
in response to this where he says empty
the till take the money and leave when
the cops show up to collect their tithe
she stabs one of them in the neck now
where the other one starts to panic this
is when like mime runs in bites the
other one Neil offers himself as a
distraction of sorts and then like
literally marionette comes running in
with basically with a with a marionette
wire and strangles the guy to death so
like right off the bat like it's
basically just the two of us where do
you like we're the only two in the world
that we can count on this is it it's
essentially like the fallout from this
whole situation and with from their
initial origin this sort of comes home
to roost when they have this
conversation because when they get back
to their safe house she's like you you
can't leave me like that like if I have
if I don't have you I don't have anybody
else like this is it because we end up
finding out that following this they
made their way on the street the best
way they could they literally did what
they had to do in order to make ends
meet so it's one of these things worse
like like look it's just us like we have
to stick together we're the only real
connection the two of us have and we
have to go find our baby together so
it's a pretty important moment and it
really gives a lot of depth to the
character enough from there the comedian
comes like tracked him down
the comedian lives up to his word he's
like I will find you literally track
them down and says you guys can come
with me and you guys can show me where
Ozymandias is or I can kill one of you
and make the other show me of course in
the midst of all this the comedian's
essentially knocked out from behind and
we end up finding the Joker was the one
who did it and so of course the Joker
steals the comedian's button and is just
kind of like oh I'm curious about this
dr. Manhattan guy look what's the deal
with this dr. Manhattan like we should
go find dr. Manhattan and this is
awesome because what it means is the
Joker will meet dr. Manhattan
here's the question you have to ask what
influence will one of them have on the
other that's what I want to know but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new year for new - covers explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you draw
unlike and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]